auch heute wollen wir uns die
militärische Situation in der Ukraine
ansehen und es gibt tatsächlich
erschreckende neue Bilder von russischen
Panzerkolonnen die in die Ukraine
hineinfahren die durch die Ukraine
fahren wir gucken uns das einfach mal
hier an endlose Panzer Bewegung
sozusagen im Osten der Ukraine diese
Aufnahmen sind aus der Region khakiv
dort
wie wir sehen wurde hier von russischen
Propagandisten gefilmt wie ein schützen
Panzer nach dem anderen es handelt sich
hier um wieder herum diese Fahrzeuge mit
dem V darauf wir gucken uns das mal an
hier sehen wir das mehrere Faust darauf
gezeichnet um das ganz genau zu erkennen
auch für die eigenen Verbände fährt hier
in die ostukrainer rein und wir wissen
mittlerweile um welche Einheiten es sich
hier handelt nämlich es ist das
eingetreten vor dem alle gewarnt haben
der Abzug vor Kiew der Abzug in den
Regionen cernyhief und zu mir im Norden
des Landes war überhaupt kein Abzug
Russland das war keine dskalation das
war keine irgendwie Verhandlungserfolg
oder ähnliches sondern es handelt es
sich um eine massive Umgruppierung neun
Tage lang sind diese Einheiten jetzt
kann man durch Russland aus dem Norden
der Ukraine heraus zeigen dass man hier
auf der Karte also im Norden der Ukraine
heraus durch Belarus und dann hier
außenrum um Russland gefahren und fahren
jetzt hier wieder rein nach hakiv und
wir gehen noch einmal zurück und schauen
mal weiter nach vorne denn bisher haben
wir hier Schützenpanzer gesehen
verschiedener Gattungen was wir hier
sehen sind russische Luft landekräfte
also die die wurden von den von dem
Propagandisten die das gefilmt haben als
die Helden von horstome bezeichnet also
die Helden der ersten Stunde die
versucht haben Kiew zu erobern die am 24
Februar gelandet sind und dann versucht
haben vorzudringen und dann vor Kiew
aber geschlagen wurden und zurück
zurückgehen mussten wir sehen am Ende
auch dass es hier massive panzerbewegung
gibt das hier ist die die vierte
panzerdivision der russischen Armee auch
die war in der Region Sumi im Norden des
Landes vorher aktiv stationiert ist sie
beim Moskau auch die ist jetzt wieder in
der Ostukraine auch die ist neu da und
bereitet hier eine massive Offensive vor
und wir haben aus verschiedenen angehört
nicht nur in der Ukraine sondern auch im
Westen befürchtet wird eine
osteroffensive befürchtet wird in der
kommenden Woche wenn diese Einheiten
alle sozusagen an ihrem Platz sind und
bereit sind eine osteroffensive vom
Putins während wir hier Ostereier
sammeln möchte er massiv in der
Ostukraine vorstoßen und dort 30.000
ukrainische Soldaten einkesseln wir
zeigen das noch mal hier die Karte haben
wir schon einige Tage lang gezeigt
dieser Plan war bisher nur ein Szenario
was wir vorgestellt haben aber jetzt
bewahrheitet es sich die ganzen
panzerweltverbände die wir gerade
gesehen haben wir zeigen das mal sind
also in die Region kakis reingefahren
und sind hier nach isium unterwegs isium
eine wichtige Stadt eine strategische
Stadt die von Russland hier besetzt
wurde und von dort aus wird versucht in
den nächsten Tagen und Wochen sozusagen
hier runterzugehen und einen riesigen
Kessel zu schließen um 30.000
ukrainische Soldaten wir hören das Putin
Zitat irgendeinen siegt bis zum 9 mai
braucht den 9 mai den Tag des Sieges der
in Russland in Moskau mit einem riesigen
Parade gefeiert wird das Sieg über Nazi
Deutschland den aber Putin digitalisiert
um den Sieg über die Ukraine oder
ähnliches zu feiern und nach der
Propaganda den Sieg über die Faschisten
in der Ukraine das dazu wir wollen uns
angucken was denn die Ukraine macht wie
sie sich darauf vorbereitet wir wissen
dass die Ukraine unterwegs ist sozusagen
in den Osten mit ihren Truppen auch die
werden jetzt verlagert von Kiew in den
Osten um dort die Gegend Offensive
einzuleiten und ganz interessante neue
Aufnahmen von ukrainischen Soldaten all
diese Fahrzeuge die wir sehen sind
russische Fahrzeuge Fahrzeuge die die
ukrainische Armee in den letzten Wochen
von Russland erbeutet hat die die Russen
und bei ihrer Flucht vor Kiew
zurückgelassen haben und auch wenn es
sich vielleicht etwas zügig anhört man
muss sagen russland ist der größte
Versorger der ukrainischen Armee mit
schweren Waffen all diese Waffen wir
sehen hier ein BTR eben gerade und BMD
hier ein T-72 auch der absolvierte erste
Schießübungen weil die Ukrainer
natürlich erstmal auf diesen neuen
Waffen überhaupt sich ausbilden müssen
die müssen erstmal gucken wie geht das
wie wie kann man damit schießen die
Ukraine selbst hat solche Panzer nicht
und auch hier sehen wir diese sehr
markante Bemalung sozusagen CDU keiner
rauf gemalt haben auf diesen Panzer um
eben ja auch den eigenen Truppen zu
zeigen dass es unser das ist keiner der
Gegner obwohl er so aussieht wie ein
gegenlicher Panzer wir sehen also hier
diese Schießübung und warten bis noch
mal einen Schuss kurz ab die ukaner
wollen also wissen wie funktioniert das
was kann man mit diesem Panzer machen
last but not least wollen wir uns auch
ansehen es sind neue westliche Waffen
angekommen in der Ukraine auch das ein
gutes Zeichen Boris johnson war gestern
in Kiew und parallel dazu oder einen Tag
danach hat die ukrainische Armee jetzt
ein Video veröffentlicht wo sie eine
hochmoderne flugabwehrwaffe
Großbritanniens testet oder bzw nutzt
und zwar die sogenannte starstreak diese
Rakete wird ja eingesetzt gegen eine
russische Drohne
und wir hören einfach mal rein in dem
Moment wo die Rakete ihr Ziel trifft
[Musik]
große Freunde Freude also hier bei den
ukrainischen Truppen die sagen super
dass wir das endlich können das war eine
kleine Drohne die ist sehr schwer zu
treffen die aber eben das
Artilleriefeuer auf die Ukrainer
koordiniert diese Truppe diese Drohne
konnte hier abgeschossen werden insofern
haben sie noch den erhobenen
Mittelfinger insofern hier große Freude
bei den Ukrainern das zumindest diese
Waffen aus dem Westen endlich da sind
funktionieren
und das ist die Lage in der Ukraine
heute